So there are actually two options here, two right answers. One way that you
could move towards having x by itself would be to multiply each side by negative
1. The coefficient here in front of x is negative 1, so if we multiply it by
negative 1, we get negative 1 times negative 1, which is just equal to positive
1, and that would leave us with x equal to 6. However, there's one other way you
could do this. You could also have said that you would divide each side by
negative 1. I'm just writing in here what you would type if this had been your
answer. The reason this works is that the coefficient here, as we said, is
negative 1. So we take negative 1 and divide by negative 1. We're just dividing
a number by itself, and we get positive 1. So once again, that would leave us
with just x by itself. And a positive 6 on the other side. So, both methods
work.